137 billion dollars that's how much
money airlines will lose to the end of
next year because of the pandemic
even as domestic air travel picks up in
some parts of the world airline losses
this year are expected to be a
staggering 51 billion before being
trimmed to 11 billion next year
all this even after u.s carriers
received 25 billion bailout last year
from the u.s government
the new financial figures are according
to the international air transport
association that represents 290 airlines
and 82 percent of the global air traffic
still a long way to go international air
travel
still heavily restricted as a result of
government measures
we know that once those restrictions are
removed the demand for travel remains
very strong but at the annual meeting in
boston the talk was also about another
emergency the airline industry is
contributing to carbon emissions
if the global airline industry was a
country it would be the world's sixth
largest polluter
out of all of the carbon emissions that
are released from passenger planes 25
percent comes from aircrafts that are
landing or taking off out of airports
here in the united states
after that the second biggest emitter is
aircraft in or out of airports in china
followed by the uk
japan and germany
the airline industry announced a goal of
net zero airline emissions by 2050
but already chinese carriers are
reluctant to agree and analysts are
skeptical that goal can even be met
in 2009 the aviation industry agreed to
cut emissions by half in 2050. if you
look what happened afterwards emissions
actually grew faster in the 10 years
after the announcement was made so
overall this is a really positive
announcement but it does point to the
need for governments to hold the
airlines to account for their actual
obligations
these are projects that literally take
carbon out of the atmosphere in an
effort to lower emissions u.s base
carrier united airlines announced it
will buy 100 fully electric commuter
planes but it will only be able to fly
400 kilometers and carry 19 passengers
in an industry with aspirational goals
to become a cleaner form of
transportation
gabriel lozando al jazeera boston